hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to shield blast this game is
made by licks Ian yes the very same
animator of some of your favorite
animations on this channel and just a
great all-around guy and I wanted to
play this game because he just released
it it's his very first game and I even
play tested it a little bit and it was
very very very very very good so I'm
gonna play it for you here I'm also
gonna provide a link down in the
description if you want you can go buy
it for yourself it's only three dollars
and it goes to support a cool guy by the
name of lik C so let me show you how it
goes before we do any of that so it's a
lot like your typical shmoop which I
like very much wait no Pam and I'm not
ready I wasn't ready hang on so this is
the main shmup patoot of it
you got your power-ups yeah there we go
okay I'm good so you got your main
shmups got your dudes here these dudes
ain't gonna hurt here your ship his
mother is shielded mother is the ship
that you're escorting to try to save
earth by getting supplies down so your
shooty Oh shooty Oh shooty an issue D an
issue D initiative if they get too close
you got a shield blast them that's how
you do it so that's the trick right you
can't be on both sides of the screen at
once unless you're really good like me
so you got to do what you got to do and
you gotta you gotta use your shield
blast which is the name of the game
right so the shield blast is like the
unique mechanic of this game and you got
to use it and time it correctly so that
you can get these [ __ ] away from
your ship no I screwed that out I
screwed that up but don't worry about it
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and eventually
you get enough money to do upgrades on
the next screen around I may actually
get to the end of this on this round
which just goes to show that I played it
a bit before ye hey hey you ugly ya out
here those six is 10 levels in each one
I know what do an amazingly let's just I
use it of
get shot [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I think actually these are better than
not to hit oh god oh god I've got oh no
no mother I'm sorry mom
oh no I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry mom
in Maine too - I ladybugs so you can't
let your your mother ship Scott shields
and you've got only a limited amount of
health that I'm about to run out of hey
go back to bug's life yeah yeah all
right all right all right all right all
right
Oh God lovely I'm doing shock oh god of
course I missed the goddamn upgrade
because I'm a fricking idiot of course I
do
uh yeah yeah no don't fall apart now
three L's and no upgrades because I'm a
damn douche but that's okay it's AMA
expert at the shield blast ability level
nine I can make it first try baby
first try I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
make it I'm not gonna make it ma
[ __ ] yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes
ow fine it's fine fine fine and dandy
Yee fine surprisingly were muffled I'm
the first try
I've got three else I can do this I
can't believe it I can do this I can do
this
oh [ __ ] okay okay okay okay yes rapid
fire yes oh this your blast
she'll blast yes oh no please please I
can't be in both Sanji ones oh boy oh
boy oh boy
please please baby chip blasted at the
ass she'll blows ah Frank look at that
bleep oh please I'm sure oh [ __ ] I
forgot that was a boss oh no no no I can
do this
I got you elf that's all I need baby oh
[ __ ] didn't that just look like that
looks so like licks in style I love it
alright you asked
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's a
bunch of leaves it ain't nothing
it ain't nothing to nobody oh [ __ ] I
keep missing all the upgrades I'm never
gonna get this guy down I can't even do
any damage to him got it got it nailing
your bill yeah oh yeah what you gonna do
oh yeah I'm doing I'm dodging yeah Oh
got the bullets out oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
god damn it one out no I'm not [ __ ]
it up now I'm gonna go the [ __ ]
dastar than my help there was a help
there I needed yes yes get out okay yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes Oh see the
shield blast can also do your bullets
out of the way which chef forgot in the
beginning phases of this fight you'll
never get there we go there we go there
we go get the tablet no no okay I'm fine
there goes health [ __ ] shitty tosser yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes Oh God why why every frickin
time
I'll get it okay I got it I don't know
how I got that but I got it got it got
it
oh yeah got it yes yes [ __ ] well can't
use this now that's unfortunate yes yes
yes Josh josh Josh josh Josh yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes no no no no no no
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no yeah
I didn't mean that but I went for it cuz
I'm a baller pusher ow
I'm a shot-caller I get stabbed in the
neck but I don't really want to be come
on come on come on come on yes yes yes
no III and chubowski yeah [ __ ] you first
try
I'm the best I'm the greatest I did it
I'm getting that hell yeah
get rekt it's a Lloyd I got you mission
accomplished
hell yeah well that's just one of three
phases now I got a lot of look I got a
lot of money I got a lot of money the
mornings mine so I'm gonna go in and I'm
gonna show you the diversity that
happens in the enemies here they do get
they do get harder because they have
different qualities throughout the
levels they got a lot of really clever
mechanics here licks in did a good job
planning this out
and just cuz I'm good at it doesn't mean
that it's easy I just happen to like
shmups oh you death shrooms get out of
there see this is where if it gets dicey
I can use the shield blast get them out
of the hole get him out of the word
Booya hahahahaha hey yeah where it gets
dicey er ye be Oh No the shield blast if
I didn't properly describe it it's the
little white pulse that comes out of the
bottom I am timing that and it's
important hence why the game is called
shield blast of Seavey's [ __ ] these
[ __ ] here yeah nice teaching me
about it looks seem good teaching level
no no no if you kill them before they go
ahead and make it a little easier on you
no yeah there we go no I missed Ellen I
miss em too cuz I'm an [ __ ] I'm
missing all of you oh no oh no oh no
because once they're invincible the only
way to get them is with the shield
blastin if you just happen to have
shield blast on cooldown I mean they
regenerate pretty oh come on they
regenerate pretty quickly
oh I wasn't paying attention I wasn't
paying a tution there we go boy oh boy
maybe I can get both levels down to one
try they're gonna do the whole game
without dying
I haven't actually beaten the 3rd level
have not the third phase whatever it is
oh no miss me miss me by that much
dillweeds got him ok level seven I'm
doing it wonderfully I'm doing amazing
no you got
barely miss that guy no come on
I'm missing all of them I am so boned
ow why did I get hit why did I let
myself get head talk [ __ ] get hit ha ha
oh [ __ ] hooah oh [ __ ] go ah okay it's
fine
no I don't like those cats those guys Oh
No Oh No
Wow exploding booms boom oh god oh god
oh god this is terrible
oh this horse so I gotta like double
make sure I'm actually in the same spot
when they die girls I'll be the one that
dies right here comes the big blasters
[ __ ] Oh God
Oh God things are going wrong things are
going so very wrong how in there we go
oh [ __ ] okay well this bad oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy
one live laughing okay there we go
we're fine ah how do the Hecky heck did
I survive that I don't know
Oh God oh god well there goes my shields
okay well well no menu let's come menu
boy oh but you can see you can see how
this game's super fun so the point is
you're not supposed to win right away
unless you're like super skilled and I'm
not the most skilled but I'm pretty good
but this has been shield blessed this is
awesome I love it it's a simple concept
but he put a lot of his own spin on it
and I just got a like applauding for the
effort he put this out its out available
on game tool right now links in the
description check it out for yourself I
really want to support licks in and I
hope you guys to play the game for
yourself and see if you like it let him
know anything you can do to improve so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out this game too the link in the
description below let me know what you
think down in the comments and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
[Music]